Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Have a look and marvel at this learning-based
assembler robot that is able to put together
simple contraptions.
Since this is a neural-network based learning
method, it needs to be trained to be able
to do this.
So, how is it trained?
Normally, to train such an algorithm, we would
have to show it a lot of pairs of the same
contraption, and tell is that this is what
it looks like when it’s disassembled, and
what you see here is the same thing, assembled.
If we did this, this method would be called
supervised learning.
This would be very time consuming, and potentially
expensive as it would require the presence
of a human as well.
A more convenient way would be to go for unsupervised
learning, where we just chuck a lot of things
on the table and say, “well, robot, you
figure it out”.
However, this would be very inefficient, if
at all possible because we would have to provide
it many-many contraptions that wouldn’t
fit on the table.
But this paper went for none of these solutions,
as they opted for a really smart self-supervised
technique.
So what does that mean?
Well, first, we give the robot an assembled
contraption, and ask it to disassemble it.
And therein lies the really cool idea, because
disassembling it is easier, and by rewinding
the process, it also gets to know how to assemble
it later.
And, the training process takes place by assembling,
disassembling, and doing it over and over
again, several hundred times per object.
Isn’t this amazing?
Love it.
However, what is the point of all this?
Instead of all this, we could just add explicit
instructions to a non-learning based robot
to assemble the objects.
Why not just do that?
And the answer lies in one of the most important
aspects within machine learning - generalization.
If we program a robot to be able to assemble
one thing, it will be able to do exactly that
- assemble one thing.
And whenever we have a new contraption on
our hands, we’ll need to reprogram it.
However, with this technique, after the learning
process took place, we will be able to give
it a new, previously unseen object and it
will have a chance to assemble it.
This requires intelligence to perform.
So, how good is it at generalization?
Well, get this, the paper reports that when
showing it new objects, it was able to successfully
assemble them 86% of the time.
Incredible.
So what about the limitations?
This technique works on a 2D planar surface,
for instance, this table, and while it is
able to insert most of these parts vertically
- it does not deal well with more complex
assemblies that require inserting screws and
pegs in a 45 degree angle.
As we always say, two more papers down the
line, and this will likely be improved significantly.
I you have ever bought a bed or a cupboard
and said, well, it just looks like a block,
how hard can it be to assemble?
Wait, does this thing have more than a 100
screws and pegs?
I wonder why?
And then, 4.5 hours later, you find out yourself.
I hope techniques like these will help us
save time by enabling us to buy many of these
contraptions pre-assembled, and it can be
used for much, much more.
What a time to be alive!
This episode has been supported by Lambda.
If you're a researcher or a startup looking
for cheap GPU compute to run these algorithms,
check out Lambda GPU Cloud.
I've talked about Lambda's GPU workstations
in other videos and am happy to tell you that
they're offering GPU cloud services as well.
The Lambda GPU Cloud can train Imagenet to
93% accuracy for less than $19! Lambda's web-based
IDE lets you easily access your instance right
in your browser.
And finally, hold on to your papers, because
the Lambda GPU Cloud costs less than half
of AWS and Azure.
Make sure to go to lambdalabs.com/papers and
sign up for one of their amazing GPU instances
today.
Our thanks to lambda for helping us make better
videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!